hey guys welcome back to my series
called introducing where I show you all
sorts of rare and strange instruments
from the past
today's instrument is my absolute
favorites this is the baroque guitar
[Music]
so the baroque guitar or the Qataris
paniolo as the Italians called it at the
time was popular between 1600 and 1750
roughly although it was actually still
being played well into the early 19th
century one of the things I love so much
about this guitar is that it was played
everywhere from the bars and streets of
eighteenth-century Madrid all the way to
the court of king charles ii and even by
king charles ii himself who studied with
the famous italian guitarist francesco
cordetta
now if you've been to many art museums
you've probably come across the painting
of a woman holding a baroque guitar or a
man serenading a love interest under a
tree and in fact people like me who
specialized in these historical
instruments we actually use those
paintings as evidence for how the
instruments were played ok so here we
have the beautiful baroque guitar and if
I hold up a modern guitar you can see
the difference in in size it's a much
thinner hourglass shape it's also quite
a bit lighter there are too many ways of
playing this instrument penteado which
means plucking and rasgueado which means
strumming
here's a short example of Pootie Otto
[Music]
now the second style Graci Otto
strumming is really where all the fun
begins
it's one of the best parts of playing
this instrument because you really
become a percussion player
[Music]
the guitarists of the time developed all
these really intricate patterns of
strumming using different combinations
of fingers and I think by far the
coolest pattern that I've come across is
called a repeat Oh a repeat oh is when
you take your middle finger and your
thumb and by rotating your forearm back
and forth you can play very fast
sixteenth notes so it's just like middle
thumb thumb middle and you just keep
rotating your arm back and forth slow it
sounds like okay so let's go for the
main differences between these two
modern guitars have they're called
machine head's these gears up here which
make it very easy to find you now if
baroque guitars use friction pegs that
are very similar to violin pegs in that
they're just wooden pegs that you turn
and that are held in with friction a lot
of modern guitarists think that these
are accrued and must not work well but
actually when they're fitted well
they're fantastic another main
difference is that modern guitars use
metal frets these little pieces of metal
here baroque guitar instead of using
metal frets uses gut and gut is
intestine dry intestines which usually
came from sheep this is real gut that I
have tied around the neck here and a lot
of guitarists today again would think oh
how crude but there's a huge advantage
with tie-down frets and that's that you
can slant and move the frets to play in
what are called temperaments and they
allow you to actually play more in tune
than fixed metal threads count the mono
guitar also has a very simple
rectangular bridge but the baroque
guitar is a bit more elegant and instead
of a simple rectangular bridge they've
turned it into a curlicue mustache now
for one of the coolest differences the
mono guitar has an open sound hole with
the little decoration around it
all day rosette whereas the baroque
guitar fitting to its name because
baroque means highly ornate baroque
guitar has an incredibly intricate
design inside of the sound hole this is
called arose and it's three-dimensional
it goes inside the instruments and in
this case it's made of goat skin so
let's talk about the tuning it has 9
strings total but we actually call this
a five-course guitar of course is a pair
of strings that we play simultaneously
so you're thinking ok five pairs of 10
strings and we even have 10 pegs here
why are the 10 strings and that's
because all the sources say that the
first string the honey was always kept
single it was called the shunter valve
which means the singing string and
actually most guitars still have 10 pegs
it's just that this one is false it's
just for symmetry so now let's compare
this tuning with that of a modern guitar
and just a quick disclaimer I'm tuned
out what's called baroque pitch which is
a equals 415 Hertz
rather than 440 Hertz and that basically
means I'm tuned one half-step below
moderate concert pitch okay the first
string on the modern classical guitar is
a high E and it sounds like this the
first spring on the baroque guitar is
the same the second string is a B and
here's where it gets interesting I have
two bees - bees and I plucked them as
one the third string is G and again I
have two g's
next we have addy and I actually have
the same deal but I also have an upper
octave that means that when I play on
that string I get parallel octaves next
we have a again I have two A's
but as you can hear they sound actually
one octave higher now because the guitar
existed for such a long period of time
in so many different countries people
experimented with different types of
strings sometimes they would have a low
a instead of too high A's sometimes they
would have to heidi's instead of one of
each the third string also occasionally
had an upper octave GE on it so compared
to a guitar this tuning is a bit odd
most guitars start high and everything
just goes lower from there this guitar
starts out high and then at the end so
it's sort of an inside-outside tuning
seventeenth-century guitar players
figured out that there was a big
advantage to this tuning and that was it
allowed you to play what they called
campanella's so the idea is rather than
playing a normal scale on a guitar
[Music]
we can play those cross string because
of the reentrant tuning and what's so
cool about that as you can hear is it
allows the notes to over ring like a
harp listen again it's a really
beautiful sound and it's also easy to
play fast and elegantly one of the best
examples of this technique comes from a
Fandango by Santiago de Murcia
[Music]
so this last piece was called Fandango
and fandango's were so popular in the
18th century especially in Spain and
Chile and Argentina the police
authorities and the church got together
and tried to band that style of music
for being played because apparently made
people so rowdy that it caused constant
street fights sexual promiscuity and
even manslaughter so this was kind of
the rock and roll of their late 18th
century broke music is actually quite a
bit like jazz and that there's so much
improvisation going on whether you're
adding extra notes and trills or
mordents or when you're strumming adding
extra divisions by instead of playing
the written rhythm which could be and
that's up to the player and it can
change every single time you play and
that's part of the magic music Baroque
guitarists like all Baroque musicians
were expected to memorize a long series
of chord progressions called grounds
this is a bit like today how any good
guitar player can just jam with it well
bar blues so if someone says hey let's
jam on the 12 bar blues and a you say
let's go so I hope you think this
instrument is as cool as I do if you
haven't already subscribed because I'm
going to be doing more videos in my
introducing series where I'm going to
teach you about more interesting plucked
instruments from the past so thanks
again for watching and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
you
[Music]